ich habe mich heute morgen wahnsinnig
geärgert ich wahnsinnig entsetzt als ich
die worte von sebastian kurz dem
österreichischen kanzler gehört habe
aber hören sie selbst
also was wir tun ist wir setzen auf
humanitäre hilfe vor ort aber wir sind
nicht bereit
freiwillig aufgaben in österreich
aufzunehmen wir haben auch schon klar
gesagt dass wir uns hier bei
solchen ideen der aufnahme nicht
beteiligen werden wir haben eine der
größten afghanischen communitys bereits
jetzt schon das ist eine massive
integrations herausforderung und wir
werden nicht zusätzlich menschen
aufnehmen die leute fahren sebastian
kurz haben mich nicht nur nachdenklich
gemacht nein sie haben mich wütend
gemacht dass es eine zutiefst unseriöse
und inhumane botschaft erstens wird
österreich sehr wahrscheinlich sowieso
flüchtlinge aufnehmen weil sie ja
hoffentlich das politische also
durchführen werden wenn es einem gelingt
nach österreich zu kommen und er ist
natürlich auch ausreichende gründe um
politisches asyl zu bekommen der zweite
punkt ist politiker müssen verantwortung
tragen auch in der kommunikation das was
er kurz da gemacht hat ist reiner
populismus er wollte den starken mann
markieren befürworter sagen um in einer
guten verhandlungsposition mit anderen
europäischen ländern zu sein das ist
aber auch für mich kein argument so
etwas zu verbreiten und damit zu zeigen
dass österreich keine flüchtlinge nehmen
würde das ist für mich auch komplett
gegen den europäischen wertekanon europa
nimmt flüchtlinge auf und da müssen alle
europäischen länder darüber reden für
mich als sebastian kurz einmal neue
gezeigt er sagt kein europa im herzen
trägt und vor allem das ja auch kein
mitgefühl hat ich könnte jetzt
moralische beispiel bringen und ihnen zu
hause erklären dass journalistinnen dort
verfolgt werden weil sie ihren job
gemacht haben dass bloggerin verfolgt
werden weil sie ihren job gemacht haben
und dann würden sie natürlich noch mehr
verstehen warum warum sollte sebastian
kurz die der nicht nehmen natürlich muss
er sie nehmen aber das möchte ich gar
nicht ich möchte nicht mit der
moralkeule kommen aber ich möchte sagen
dass dieser mann keine verantwortung als
politiker in der kommunikation
übernommen hat
nun ist es so nina das populismus ja für
sebastian kurz nichts neues ist ja
regiert mit populismus und das muss man
sagen sehr erfolgreich aber in diesem
thema
wer sich wirklich verrannt für mich am
erstaunlichsten ist einmal es geht ja
nicht hier um 1000 ist es richtig dass
wien eine sehr große afghanische
community hatte dass er bei der letzten
flüchtlingswelle auf die meisten
flüchtlinge aufgenommen haben gemessen
an den proportionen der population der
bevölkerung aber hier geht es ja nicht
um tausende sondern wahrscheinlich um
ein paar hundert menschen die den besten
geholfen haben in afghanistan und die
schutz suchen weiterhin für mich am
erstaunlichsten ist aber was die grünen
machen diese nämlich seinen
koalitionspartner haben bei der letzten
wahl in wien also in österreich ungefähr
14 prozent geholt haben gesagt da setzt
wenn man grüne politik durch und die
sind jetzt mucksmäuschenstill stimmen
sogar innerhalb des koalitionsvertrages
nicht dagegen können sie nicht sondern
sie müssen mit stimm oder sich eben
entsprechend enthalten das heißt das ist
ja eine krasse gegensätzliche politik
gegenüber dem was grüne politik ist der
kennst du dich ja auch besonders gut aus
und hier hören wir nichts übrigens vor
einem jahr als dieses flüchtlingsdrama
war auf moorea das flüchtlingslager auf
moorea in moria die insel auf der insel
lesbos war es ähnlich da haben die
grünen in österreich ebenfalls nichts
getan nichts gesagt aber es rumort
natürlich sie verlieren prozent sind
jetzt schon ein ständig geworden und ich
denke das wird konsequenzen haben auch
für die partei weder du bist ja auch
pr-profi wir sehen ja bei sebastian kurz
und das haben wir in der bundesregierung
auch gesehen 2016 als wir die
flüchtlingskrise ja hier auch zu
bewältigen hatten migrationspolitik am
ende ist auch pr politik das heißt wenn
sebastian kurz so etwas sagt dann hat
das natürlich auch signalwirkung erstmal
an viele viele menschen die
möglicherweise nach europa oder nach
österreich kommen wollen ich erinnere
mich daran dass die bundesregierung 2016
sogar eine plakataktion in afghanistan
gestartet hat und gesagt hat bitte
bleibt hier bitte bleib hier kommt nicht
nach deutschland also was ist das jetzt
anders ich glaube dass sebastian kurs in
österreich ganz wohl und sehr wohl auch
flüchtlingskonvention erfüllen werden
also wenn da jemand klopft dann wird es
in österreich kein rechtsstaat war und
das war nicht gerade sagen weil er
natürlich das signal senden will bis
2015 aus deutschland kam kommt doch
bitte alle hierher sondern eher wieder
andere signale senden mitte versucht
doch einfach wenn ihr kommen wollt geht
woanders hin
dann hätte er auch das sagen muss also
wenn das eine pr-aktion da sein sollte
würde ich das thema gründlich misslungen
er sagt ja in seinem statement auch was
ja auch wichtig ist dass man versuchen
muss die menschen die aus afghanistan
flüchten müssen in die nachbarländer
aufzunehmen es ist ja niemandem damit
getan wenn sie über ganze kontinente
flüchten müssen sich da in große gefahr
begeben das ist glaube ich unbestritten
aber zu sagen wir nehmen niemanden auf
ist genauso quatsch wie zu sagen kommt
alle hierher also weder da noch was
gesagt er hat ja im interview noch
gesagt dass er sich für die humanitäre
vor allem ohne ihre hilfe vor ort
einsetzen müsste das heißt ganz klar ist
ja richtig das ist richtiger punkt und
ich glaube einfach er will ein gewisses
signal setzen wissen aus der folge von
2015 dass das innenpolitisch nicht nur
in österreich aber auch in anderen
europäischen ländern zu massiven
spannungen geführt da zu sagen wenn ihr
kommen wollt versucht doch erstmal nicht
zu uns zu kommen sondern versuche aber
so hat das nicht gesagt wenn dann hätte
ja sozusagen er hat gesagt niemand kommt
in mein land und das ist noch mal eine
ganz andere aussage und die halte ich
für falsch und auch gefährlich das ist
bewährten herr alexander starke worte
sind in der politik hoffen zeichen von
schwäche und das ist so ein fall
sebastian kurz steht innenpolitisch sehr
unter druck es gab einen schlimmen
mordfall in österreich von afghanen
beteiligt waren und was er tut er nimmt
sich eine außenpolitische option weil es
geht ja also das um die lenden um
afghanistan herum geholfen werden soll
das ist konsens aber es kann ja sein
dass so viele kommen dass man diesen
ländern anbieten muss kontingente zu
übernehmen und das ist auch in den
verhandlungen mit diesen ländern wichtig
und dass er für österreich diese sache
jetzt vom tisch nahm zeigt dass er in
politik über außenpolitik stellt und das
sollte ein bundeskanzler nicht tun
sebastian kurz ist populist genug aber
auch erfahren genug als politiker um zu
wissen dass solche worte auslösen oder
will natürlich da den rechten rand der
stark die fpö die er aus der regierung
heraus hat wird natürlich stärker jetzt
quer durch impfgegner und alu hütte und
all diese verqueren menschen dort auch
um diese komponente derjenigen die sagen
keine neuen flüchtlinge das will er
nicht zulassen und er weiß natürlich was
er damit auslöst mit diesen worten auch
in abgrenzung zu dem was wirklich
möglicherweise kommen kann aber es ist
ja ein gewisser weise eine gewisse
ehrlichkeit die aus den worten spricht
also in deutschland sie wissen weist die
bundesregierung nicht mal wie viel
ortskräfte überhaupt kommen sollen die
zahlen gehen von 10.000 bis 40.000 wie
viele da sind weiß man auch nicht
vollkommen richtig auch das weiß man
nicht also ich glaube dass ich jetzt ein
bisschen schwer die wälder hervor reich
sein sachen zu vermischen ortskräfte
wollen wir nehmen die müssten meiner
meinung nach erst gar nicht ins
asylverfahren wer uns geholfen hat der
soll von unserer regierung hier
eingeladen werden und sebastian kurz
weiß so wenig wie jeder andere politiker
in europa was da jetzt passiert und wenn
er einfluss darauf nehmen will dass
europa eine vernünftige
migrationspolitik macht dann kann er
jetzt nicht vom tisch nehmen dass sich
sein österreich an einem kontingent
beteiligt deshalb ich hoffe ich
wiederhole mich nicht macht er einen
innenpolitischen punkte béla anda ja
eigentlich auch gesagt und nimmt sich
damit außenpolitische positionen und
wäre ich österreicher wird mich das
ärgert mich
hat es ich bin ja deutschen user
michaelis komplett entsetzt ehrlich
gesagt weil ich finde man wünscht sich
doch als politiker jemanden der genau
seine worte abwägt und der b
verantwortung übernimmt aber dann auch
verantwortung ein statement heraus zu
geben was auch möglich ist weil dass
österreich kein aufnehmen das ist ja gar
nicht möglich da würde er das komplette
asylrecht außer kraft setzt aber dennoch
glaubt ihr den ernsthaftesten österreich
wenn wir kein normales asylverfahren
laufen würde wenn da jetzt afghanen vor
der tür stehen doch natürlich über das
heißt seine aussage ist doch komplett
falsch und dann ist das also bitte aber
eher misslungen die fraktion dass ich
wissen die pr aktion funktioniert nicht
funktioniert so weit als er ein
stoppschild setzt und sagt passau
versucht erst mal nicht bei uns aber was
wäre das für eine möglichkeit für grüne
sich zu profitieren was wäre
normalerweise los in eine solche politik
macht würde bei allem realismus der
eingekehrt ist auch bei den grünen die
sagen natürlich darf hier nicht jeder
kommen und nicht schleusen artig hier
dürfen nicht zigtausende kommen aber es
müssen diejenigen kommen können die uns
geholfen haben möglicherweise und
asylverfahren wo ist denn die stimme
dauert der grünen des koalitionspartners
immer in die normalerweise das zum thema
machen müssen sie sagen
nicht mit uns nicht in dieser coolen was
ich ja jetzt auch zeigt dass für die
probleme von dem wir 2015 schon wussten
dass wir sie haben dass wir eben keine
abgestimmte europäische asylpolitik und
flüchtlingspolitik haben dass wir in
deutschland immer noch kein vernünftiges
einwanderungsgesetz haben es zeigt sich
jetzt dass das diese lücken da sind und
dass wir jetzt wieder
in dem wissen dass wir da ungelöste
probleme haben wieder auf so eine sache
zu steuern und das sollte doch jetzt der
weckruf sein für jeden verantwortungs
politiker verantwortlich die politiker
jetzt endlich danach zu arbeiten und zu
sehen dass wir eine abgestimmte gute
flüchtlingspolitik bekommt dass
deutschland endlich ein
einwanderungsgesetz bekommen wo wir
wirklich auch trennen zwischen
zuwanderung auf dem arbeitsmarkt die wir
dringend brauchen zwischen humanitärer
hilfe zwischen asyl all diesen dingen
das ist ja längst überfällig und das
müssen wir natürlich tun aber ich glaube
er hat sich einiges bewegt
habe er in der welt am sonntag bei uns
ein interview gegeben mit der
überschrift wir müssen uns genau
angucken wer da kommt es hätte man
sicher 2015 von den grünen so hätte man
es nicht gelesen
frau berg hat gesagt wir müssen ein
kontingent nehmen im fünfstelligen
bereich und ein kontingent ist ja
eigentlich eine obergrenze ist ein
anderes wort dafür war ein kontingent
das irgendwann voll also da hat sich
auch auf der grünen seite einiges bewegt
aber das ist wie bei alexander jeweils
ganz anderes die position zu revidieren
oder ein bisschen abzuschwächen als
komplett zu schweigen bei jemandem der
sagt hier kommt kein mensch ins land ich
wollte das gar nicht gleich setzt und
ich finde auch was sie erzählt das
stimmt ja dass die österreichischen
grünen einen koalitionsvertrag
unterschreiben wo steht in einem
bestimmten thema werden wir im parlament
gerne von rechtspopulisten überstimmt
das ist ja völlig irre also das würden
die wir uns ja nie machen eine besondere
österreichische situation
[Musik]